how laughable was it to you when liver
King said he was on all night oh that's
hilarious yeah yeah we all knew even to
me it was hilarious
I mean he's how red that [__]
all the time like that
[Music]
all right so um apparently correct me if
I'm wrong UFC Legend Mr Mazda doll has
retired yeah retired what he said that's
a real he really retired he really
retired what was the reason he got oh he
got old some of the internet saying is
because the Drake curse striked again oh
bro mazovar's been fighting for so long
and at the highest level for so long fan
I like him yeah I'm a big Master fan
I'll be brave enough to admit it I was
after you humbled himself huh dude how
do I win I was after he humbled his ass
like he humbled himself after he lost
the after been asking who did he lose to
by Usman
[__] up is it because aspirin lost to
[__] Paul so he was like you know
what if I can't be uh no he remember he
flying need him in the face remember
that one it was like one of the fastest
scales I think right but yeah no early
in his career man he was a killer and I
think he he got famous a little later in
his career if he got a little more
famous like in middle man he he was he
had some great fights like the amount of
miles that's on him because he started
in like the Kimbo Slice backyard days
yeah oh yeah that's right so that was
hella long ago it has had a [__] ton of
fights sanctioned or not sanctioned so
he's just been in the game for a long
time and I think professional fights
even what was like 50 years I think like
50 fights yeah 30 something in like 12
or something damn so he's pretty she's
old for that world Ben yeah and I think
towards his last couple of fights he's
dealing with injuries he's dealing with
um like as you're getting older it's
hard to make the weight and just a lot
more complications and then the people
that he's fighting are coming up really
hungry and strong so I think for him
it's just it's time to like check out he
knew he only had like a fight or two
left and yeah how often is UFC in Miami
where he's from yeah like I want to
retire out of my in my town he knew he
had nothing left he had to do that he
was going to retire before he did he
said if you can't get it done he's gonna
retire because he wanted to do the title
fight because the current champ is he
had uh he has a really good storyline
with the current champ so he had to beat
this guy to get the title shot who's the
current champ his name is Leon Edwards
He's a he's a British lad a British lad
he's Jamaican Jamaican and the good
story is he socked him up backstage
before yeah they were like talking [__]
and he like punched him in the face and
it was like that's when mozamadol
started getting really famous because I
give him two pieces of soda yeah with a
three-piece and a son three pieces and
he just punched them and then cut him
open and that was like the whole
storyline and that's when everyone was
like dude miles of it all sick he's
gangster he's like Scarface dude
everybody loved that they call him
Street Jesus that's the part that kind
of sucks sometimes where like you have
that really juicy story and actually
that would make a great fight because
Mavado is a really good Striker Leon
Edwards is a really good Striker it
would be an amazing fight to watch but
to get there he had to fight Gilbert
Burns who's the best jujitsu guy like
one of the best Jiu Jitsu guys in the
UFC so it's almost as if yeah he has to
fight a tougher and hard harder and
potentially less entertaining fight to
get to the to complete the story but he
wasn't able to get past and what a great
storyline if you did it yeah but then
again like you see mozaval the last
fight you're like he's still great he's
well yeah but he's like he doesn't look
as sharp as he used to because we've
seen him fight so many times before you
we have a good accurate assessment of
like how good mosquito is what he looks
like in this fight you're like ah he
just doesn't look he got tired all there
you know but it just I think this is the
old age and the the miles and he's like
he's building all these other businesses
yeah like he said he's like I hope like
you know I've had a great career and
like this is the best way for me to go
out yeah he's like I have to do what I
wanted to do it started from nothing and
now I get to live the rest of my life
you did mention that he's a
multi-millionaire too and that's
starting from nothing he's always he's
gonna be a legend right because he can
afford to retire a lot of Fighters can't
yeah seriously he set himself up how
does it feel though to retire like on a
loss I don't know I think in a sport I
don't know I think most people do I
think yeah to be honest especially in
fighting fighting is tough bro like you
got to get out early you kind of have
like like what Habib did you got out
like right when he was he's one of those
yeah but didn't he only have so many
fights real realistically In This Moment
yeah but even the greats they start I
mean like Pacquiao he's been losing and
then he just I don't know if he's fully
retired but it's just hard to cash out
at the right time yeah you know what I
mean I know what you mean
and he was like this is it yeah it could
have gone back and fought five more
fights probably in one yeah he could
probably be 35 and all right now he's
kind of still proving he's like the best
guy but he's like in fighting dude your
brain damage like this yeah that's crazy
and training for a fight that's the
hardest part really like that's when you
really get [__] up people like and
then and then you fight and then you get
damaged even more you get concussion you
get you know Cuts over your eyes it's
like there's no way to live dude that's
why Conor he's out so he doesn't he kind
of comes in dips his toes in but he made
his millions
yeah you know like what is that I know
he has a fight though doesn't he coming
up yeah but that might be his last one
these are all super wide now yeah hey
what do you think hey what do you think
about Connor you think the G8 [__] you
think he's on something yeah he got
steroid face now he kind of his face
looks all floated looking he looks
juiciest he like lost his neck yeah he's
probably taking some GH I would say yeah
because there was a controversy with
Conor going back into fighting right
because when you go back you have to go
back in the you saw the drug testing
pool I only need six months I'm gonna
say this and I don't care that it's on
record I know
a lot of guys that their jobs and they
sign ndas and everything or to literally
help athletes cheat yeah I know like
that's their profession yeah they're
literally colleagues of mine it's a good
gig how how does one hypothetically help
an athlete cheat you just what's a job
title you know
a sports scientist oh that's my title oh
so you uh know what performance
enhancing drugs to take that will not
uh whatever testing metric they use
because not everybody uses usada or
water or whatever it may be you just
know how to beat that basically you know
what Esther so when Esther is like the
length of time that a compound will stay
in the system actually so yeah
true and that's okay
or like the performance enhancing things
that's undetectable like ginseng sure
ginseng and ashwagandha bro what about
rhinos horns there are things that are a
lot more uh beneficial than that that
aren't cordyceps
cilantro
so yeah he's on stuff he's on it oh [__]
so we're half half the athletes in
California that play basketball and
whatever so like you can but they they
is it like dosing them correctly and
knowing like what to do so even if
they'd get a random test it's
undetectable a lot of that yeah and
honestly in in those types of scenarios
it's not it's not random because I heard
that in the Olympics everybody there's
somebody telling you oh they'll though
you get a you get a oh yeah so they're
like in Olympics it's like everyone does
it but then everyone also well those
athletes are on a four-year cycle so
it's a lot easier actually those are the
athletes are the easiest to help cheat
for your cycle like you bring in that's
why China does it the way they do like
you'll see like uh do you know lahoy he
came in he was like a weightlifter
um nobody knew who the [__] he was until
like 2012 or something like that
um because he was one of the four
athlete like four athletes that they had
basically on the back burner where they
were just gassing them the [__] up
getting them strong as hell and then the
athletes that were current were like
they swapped them out and like these
guys were gassed to the gills but now
they're just uh natural but they're
training with those same numbers and
then they go to the Olympics and it's
like whoa holy [__] that guy's really
strong first place so they just have to
like John and Rush are the same they
just have to cut out the the like
steroids before it's in a testable time
period or something sometimes that
sometimes you can take things to mass
things sometimes you can just like have
it in basically all the way up to the
competition the correct Ester and like
you'll never know that it wasn't your
system is there any natural athletes
that are just phenoms and they're good
absolutely really oh yeah yeah tons
especially like people who are first
coming up in like the UFC and [__] those
types of guys those are like Yola Romero
legit real killers yeah they're insane
uh but then you know they go through
their career and they're like I'm not
keeping up with that guy there's a
reason for that how many people though
like in that professional athletic any
industry though is like you would want
to stay natural but then when you look
at your fellow competitors and like just
to hold up to that level you're like
[__] I might as well as there's probably
a lot of pressure like right especially
like like he was talking about with uh
Samoans and how our Polynesians I guess
in the NFL and stuff um
it's they're so [__] big so athletic
and so strong naturally that some of
them probably have never touched
anything in their lives but then you get
like a fat white guy from Missouri like
somebody I went to high school with or
something like this guy's kicking my ass
what do I do to keep up with him they do
that they're gonna [__] start taking
some [__] yeah like so that's probably a
lot of pressure jobs on the line right
yeah yeah it's everything yeah
damn you see everybody else doing it
like how do you how do you not I wonder
if that's how mathletes feel like like
they're all on Adderall yeah no they're
not like I need to compete yeah they're
like there's no way yeah yeah can you
can you look at somebody and be like
you're on some [__]
for the most part like for the most part
what am I on yeah what about but also no
like one of my uh
how laughable was it to you when liver
King said he was on all night oh that's
hilarious yeah yeah we all knew even to
me it was hilarious yeah I mean he just
read that [__] is all the time
like
well I sent you liver King and I was
like is he on steroids because he's
claims he's just eating liver all day
but I don't have the steroid eyes yeah
like I wouldn't know like like
bartimedia was like yeah the shoulders
the ABS or whatever and I'm like I
wouldn't know you saw the specific stack
he was on right like yeah is it like way
too much for someone absolutely he's way
too [__] small for being on all that
[__] this should be bigger so at that
point like what are the consequences for
him like does he is he gonna is he
probably gonna die sooner like if he
continues yeah I mean the higher your
anabolic androgenics are like you're
you're taking time off your life but
he's gonna die buffer but he'll die a
big box
an extra large coffin yeah that's a big
coffin
go get that coffin wide please I've seen
guys
get off of it and then there they shrink
like crazy and then they they're like
they look like a different person for
sure what the hell what that's clay so
cutting steroid use uh can you go back
to to completely normal healthy like I
mean it depends on what you mean because
there's even just with lifting weights
you already experienced a lot of this
but like
actual cardiac hypertrophy so your heart
actually growing is a thing and steroids
can actually kind of increase that even
more so there are things that happen to
you internally that you're not going to
reverse yet Western medicine's fixing
that slowly but surely like we might all
just live forever steroids make your
heart bigger the episode is training
with weights like athlete heart is like
when you have left ventricular
hypertrophy you just want to mitigate
that as much as possible which is like
routine ultrasounds and [__] are a good
idea so even without just being natural
like athlete athletes they have big
hearts yeah you can get a lot of that
because I mean it's pumping more than
most people because you're actually
active so is that a good thing no no you
don't want a lot of it suddenly Bart's
concerned I was like yeah that's a good
thing bigger heart bigger biceps dude
sorry Jared
he's got it pumps more Blood Out come on
[Music]
foreign